now we're all aware of security and
privacy concerns that surround our use
of emails and social media whether it's
phishing scams trojan horses you name it
but now with the proliferation of mobile
devices that track our movements and
initiate interactions those concerns are
even more acute and if you like me
you're worried about keeping your
personal information safe I'm lucky I'm
joined by two experts on privacy and
security in this brave new world Peter
drew Shore who's the scientific director
of the Max Planck Institute for software
systems and stefan suru a senior
researcher at Microsoft Research welcome
gentlemen and you Peter we'll start with
you what concerns you most these days in
terms of privacy well one concern has to
do with these many popular applications
and services that keep track of people's
locations there are physical activities
their health status and increasingly
also their social encounters now in the
one hand these applications are
fantastic because they help people
organize their lives you know stay fit
and healthy and also get in touch with
some of the people in their vicinity but
on the other hand are these applications
and services really take the privacy
risks to an entirely new level because
they really blur the distinction between
online and offline worlds and not only
recording you know your online activity
which is deliberate and voluntary but
they sort of seamlessly track your
physical whereabouts and that is you
know something that raises the question
of what happens to the data that's being
recorded and I think that's something
we'll really have to pay attention to so
they can get hold of the information
exploited I mean how exactly do they do
that well the problem starts with the
fact that these applications really
store and collect and store this data
and initially store it on your mobile
device so for instance if they know you
contract some malware which is easy
enough to do you go to the wrong website
you open an email attachment or you fall
for one of the phishing attacks that
malware can compromise your phone and
potentially get access and expose that
kind of data another important risk is
that you know many of these apps
actually upload that data to the app
providers cloud website and at that
point the user really has no control or
not even knowledge of what happens to
the data from that point
on and and how do we counter these
threats are there you know their tools
or behaviors that we should adopt
prevent its unwanted spying right well
in terms of tools they're really there
really isn't that much available today
in production I you all know when you
install an app you're supposed to grant
permission for that app to installs or
you know to access certain information
like your contacts or you'll get access
to certain sensors like your location
provider but quite often write these
requests seem plausible to us and we're
interested in the functionality that
this application provides so we grant it
and this is really an all-or-nothing
decision because you know once the
application is access to the information
we don't really know and can't control
what happens you know how it's being
used how it's being disseminated now
there is quite a bit of research in the
area right there are people working on
techniques to try to track the flow of
information through such applications
there are people working on encryption I
think Stefan is that going to talk about
that a little bit we've also been
working on something towards developing
and a communication platform then
enables such apps to you know contact
and communicate with nearby devices but
in a way that keeps the user in control
of their privacy and I gather there's
another aspect and that's the privacy of
by standards and can you describe the
issue here yes so this is a related
aspect then it's got to do with the fact
that our smartphones and increasingly
variable devices have the sophisticated
audio visual audio visual capture
capabilities which has led actually to
commend how the new creative outlets you
know people are taking videos and
pictures all the time upload them on
facebook on YouTube that's a fantastic
thing but the thing that really hasn't
been addressed is that quite often in
social situations you know unrelated
bystanders just incidentally get
captured in such a recording and in many
situations they're not actually okay
with that all right I mean this is kind
of a different issue isn't it it short
of going around getting signed
permission of all these people and all
these people might be on your social
media how can you avoid invading their
privacy well it's in that you'd lead a
challenge because on the one hand you
want to respect people's privacy on the
other hand you want to
preserve the spontaneity and ubiquity of
this kind of digital capture so we've
been working actually on a prototype
where the idea is to enable people to
state their preferences with respect to
capture privacy in dependent on their
current context so they can say for
instance when I'm among friends you know
restrictions on image capture when I'm
at the workplace also no restriction but
when I'm in public you know I want to
have my face blurred and when I'm not at
the beach or a similar location like the
gym or a health care facility I don't
want to have my image captured at all
this would be recorded by my own smart
device my smartphone for instance and
then appetizer to nearby capture devices
over a short-range radio and capture
devices in their platform would then
being able to essentially receive this
press their preferences and check and a
captured image to see if some bystander
was captured and then you know edit the
media the video or the image to respect
that person's privacy and and out of the
public view these inadvertent privacy
invasions well that's an interesting
question there is some work on that from
social scientists and we've also done a
small-scale online survey on this and
essentially the outcomes are that on the
one hand people's preferences with
respect to this kind of capture a very
situational right it depends on the
context you know who's around me am I
among friends among strangers who's the
photographer right is it a friend is it
someone in some kind of an official
function like a wedding photographer or
is it a complete stranger and secondly
what we found this and others have found
as well is that there are considerable
individual differences among preferences
that people have in the same situation
it seems to be a cultural and brave and
personal thing and thanks very much for
that Stefan I'm I want to ask you the
same opening question I asked Peter what
concerns you most these days about
privacy and security so you know
everything that Pierre said actually
concerns me as well but additionally i
think that concerns me is that the ease
by which you know these mobile devices
that were carrying how easily they're
lost or stolen arguably i think is
pretty clear that that mobile you know
smartphones and tablets are much more
easily lost or stolen than
desktops where are even laptops and um
can encryption solve this problem right
so so you know for a long time people
were worried about last devices
especially with laptops and both the
industry and research community
basically came up with these systems
that offer encryption of your data and
what they do is that the guarantee they
offer is called protecting data at rest
so whenever the data is stored on your
hard drive on your storage system the
data is encrypted and the keys that we
use to actually encrypt these data are
protected by some password or pin that
the user is asked to enter when these
devices actually start up and because
most of the time laptops are either shut
down or hibernating this is an adequate
sort of security model on the other hand
tablets and smartphones are rarely shut
down they are often in this sleep state
and only texts you know pressing the
power button actually they resumed
operation and have all these data are
lying unencrypted Lee in there ramps and
both enterprises and device owners are
very very concerned with a number of
attacks that can be mounted to still you
know data unencrypted data lying in
these devices memories I'm what kind of
attacks i mean you know other any
current or potential technological
solution yeah do these definitely these
attacks have been known for a long time
you know they basically are referred to
in the literature as memory attacks and
one class of attacks are called boot
attacks where we're actually it turns
out that when when a piece of memory
loses power it still preserve its
contents for a short period of time this
is referred to the data remnants
property that memory has so the attack
typically is that you know I can
basically steal your phone and maybe we
flash it with my own software and while
it's be flashing and going through that
reboot cycle I can the memory still
preserve some of its contents and I can
read them that way but they're also but
what's what they're called bus
monitoring the attacks were actually
look at the data that flows between your
your process or in the memory and there
are actually trivial devices that
actually inspect to read this memory
traversing these buses in fact there is
a company that sells a bus marketing
device that you can plug in your iPad
and turn
from your iPad into this device that can
read secrets from memory Wow and
encryption technologies I'm were they
you know are they available yes yes yes
so so basically what sort of the next
barrier for us or the next sort of goal
for us is to make sure that data stays
or sensitive data at the very least
remains encrypted even when it's in
memory so the the model you know the
system that we're actually going the
words is one where every time sensitive
data leaves the boundary or the
perimeter of the processor is going to
be encrypted so the only place when the
data is actually unencrypted is in the
processor and mounting the tax on the
processor is much more difficult much
more costly and you know where we build
a system like that where you know we can
take your email or you and your contact
information and make sure that whenever
you process on that it has this property
that all data is encrypted when it lies
in memory um what do you suggest people
do in the meantime and how long I've got
to wait for right right this encryption
pro so encrypted memory actually if you
look at the industry trends it's coming
down the road the hardware manufacturers
are sort of you know putting resources
into coming up with hardware solutions
to make sure that our memory is
encrypted at all times nevertheless I
harder only solution is actually
expensive and it's difficult to adopt
because building hardware is expensive
and deploying the practice takes you
know several iterations of the market to
sort of be near their devices so that's
why in the meantime we've been working
on software only solutions that leverage
today's hardware to actually provide
these guarantees nevertheless the harder
solution will be much more performant
much better so I expect probably in
about a decade that most of the devices
you're going to find these stores are
going to have at least some form of
encrypted memory in them and the Peter
I'd like you to ask answer the same sort
of question about how do people protect
themselves now in terms of social media
apps and from having information stolen
well I think the only general advice one
could give is to be judicious in
selecting application like a plus that
we install and services that we sign up
right so in general one shouldn't just
evaluate these kinds of apps and
services by the functionality they
provide that's usually very appealing
but ask you know what databases collect
is there a legitimate need for that data
to be collected and what happens to that
data later on now in general it's
difficult to answer these questions
particularly for a layperson but one
could for instance look you know does
the provider have a privacy statement
does that answer such questions that I
just asked right use the provider a
reputable company that operates in a
jurisdiction that can be expected to to
enforce these kinds of rules and have
laws that respect privacy Stephan Peter
thank you and for your information is so
if somewhat a little bit dis questioning
about privacy and security in the world
of mobile devices and now let's go back
to the vemma floor where scarlet has
drummed up some pretty information
pretty good information for us